Uh, okay.
Let's go next to our caller from the a two
oh six area code.
Who's calling today from two Oh six David?
Yes.
Hey David.
I'm Jessie.
I'm from the Seattle area.
Hey Jesse.
What's going on?
Um, so I've, you know, I just recently got
on Twitter and I've noticed, I'm curious,
do you think that us who listened to work
the rest of the media kind of in a bubble,
because I've noticed that a lot of people
actually really, really do like Bergen standards.
Well, so you're saying you're seeing tweets
from who don't like Bernie?
Yeah, but it's pretty widespread.
In what sense
is it?
It's
right.
It's like a lot of the big lefties on Twitter
are very, very anti Bernie Sanders.
Like who?
And No, anyone in the establishment, just
people who are very popular and put for Harping
on Donald Trump or whatever.
So like who would it be an example of that?
Oh, there's a Twitter account called the resistance
or something like that
and the resistance doesn't like burning.
Yeah.
And I get into these big Twitter wars and
a lot of times I've noticed that a lot of
people from the left sound exactly like Donald
Trump supporters and they pair it like Fox
News media coverage on Bernie Sanders.
Like what would be an example of a Fox narrative
on Bernie that the left parrots,
um, the other day I got into an argument with
someone and they were saying, you know, I
said, look at Bernie Sanders past with his
comments on all the major issues.
They haven't changed at all.
And people say things like, um, well, you
know, Biden's better because he shows that
he can change and things like that.
And also
that's not unique to Bernie.
That's a really old, that that's a talking
point.
In order to be able to take both sides of
flip flops and either way defend your candidate.
Here's the thing, Twitter is not the real
world.
Okay.
I am going to base my assessment of how favorably
people look at Bernie, not based on my personal
interactions on Twitter.
I'm going to look at actual properly sampled
favor ability polls and that, that's what
I would be looking at.
And Bernie is, you know, mildly popular in
the context of politicians who mostly are
not like the most liked people in a huge partisan
divide.
So I would go buy that.
I'm not gonna, I wouldn't go by my personal
interactions on Twitter.
And by the way, if I were you, I'd probably
stop even getting into those arguments on
Twitter.
It's, it's just depressing and stressful.
It's a waste of time.
Yeah, I can agree with that.
I've kind of stopped.
Yeah.
Good.
All right, very good.
Appreciate the phone call.
Great to hear from you.
And uh, on that note, I will go to a break
and I will take calls again.
Sorry for everyone that I was not able to
get you today.